ينهار أكبر مستشفى في غزة تحت
وطأة أطباء الحرب في
مستشفى ألفا الذين يسعون جاهدين لإبقاء المرضى على
قيد الحياة وسط انقطاع التيار الكهربائي والنقص الحاد
بما في ذلك هؤلاء
الأطفال المبتسرين الملفوفين بالرقائق والبطانيات في
محاولة يائسة لإبقائهم على قيد الحياة خارج
حاضناتهم في ساحة المستشفى بالعشرات.
من الجثث المتحللة ببطء، والتي لا يمكن
دفنها، تعرض مجمع المستشفى للقصف
بشكل متكرر وسط قتال قريب
مع مسلحي حماس،
ويقترب الجيش الإسرائيلي الآن من اتهام حماس
بإدارة مركز قيادة وسيطرة تحت الأرض
أسفل
المنشأة الطبية المترامية الأطراف والمتعددة المباني الموجودة
هنا.  مستشفى الصفا حيث تدير حماس
بعض خلايا القيادة والسيطرة الخاصة بها،
هذا هو المكان الذي تقود فيه الهجمات الصاروخية المباشرة
قوات كاماس، لكن
الجيش الإسرائيلي يقول إن هذه الصورة، التي
لا تستطيع CNN التحقق منها بشكل مستقل، تظهر
موقع تلك المرافق الموجودة تحت الأرض،
والآن بينما تحاصر القوات الإسرائيلية
المستشفى  مسؤول أمريكي يدعم
مزاعم إسرائيل التي تقول إن حماس لديها
مركز قيادة تحت المستشفى وتستخدم
الوقود المخصص للمستشفى
وتضع مقاتليها داخل وحول
مجمع المستشفى الليلة
ويقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه عثر على مخبأ
الأسلحة في قبو
مستشفى آخر في أوران  مستشفى الأطفال الذي
تم إخلاؤه في نهاية هذا الأسبوع، نعم، إنها
سترة واقية للإرهابيين لتفجيرها على
القوات بين المستشفيات بين المرضى،
كما كشف الجيش الإسرائيلي عن
مدخل النفق هذا الذي يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي
إنه بجوار مدرسة وعلى بعد حوالي 200 ياردة
من نفس المستشفى، ترتدي امرأة
ملابس  وحبل
ويقولون إنهم عثروا على علامات تشير
إلى احتمال احتجاز رهائن إسرائيليين
في قبو المستشفى اليوم،
ويقول الجيش الإسرائيلي أيضًا إنه فتح النار
على مقاتلي حماس الذين كانوا مختبئين
بين المدنيين عند مدخل
مستشفى عال حيث أطلق هذا الرجل صاروخًا.
يمكن رؤية قنبلة يدوية في لقطات طائرات بدون طيار
نشرها الجيش الإسرائيلي. حماس تنفي
أنها تعمل في المستشفيات. هناك بعض
الأدلة السابقة التي تربط حماس بالمستشفى.
كتبت منظمة العفو الدولية أنه في عام 2014 قامت حماس
باستجواب وتعذيب
المتعاونين الإسرائيليين المزعومين في
عيادة خارجية مهجورة داخل  أراضي
مستشفى الشفاء الرئيسي في مدينة غزة،
فتح الجيش الإسرائيلي ممرات
لإجلاء الأشخاص داخل مستشفى الشفاء وما حوله،
لكن المسؤولين الطبيين هناك يقولون إنه
لا توجد طريقة لإجلاء العديد من
مرضاهم البالغ عددهم 700 مريض
في الوقت الحالي، والعديد منهم محاصرون ببساطة جيريمي
دايموند سي إن إن أشالون
إسرائيل